>>> JOINING US IS CHRISTIANE
AMANPOUR, WHO INTERVIEWED
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY AND THE
FIRST LADY LAST MONTH.
THIS IS JUST INCREDIBLY
SIGNIFICANT.
IT'S BEEN 300 DAYS, HE HAS NOT
LEFT UKRAINE.
AND NOW HIS FIRST TRIP OUTSIDE
DURING THIS WAR IS TO THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Reporter: ABSOLUTELY,
KAITLAN.
AND, OF COURSE, THE UNITED
STATES IS HIS BIGGEST BACKER AND
HE HAS THANKED THEM OVER AND
AGAIN, INCLUDING IN MY INTERVIEW
AND THANKED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
KNOWING IT IS TAXPAYERS' MONEY
HELPING UKRAINE WITH THE WEAPONS
IT NEEDS.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
PUNCTUATION POINT BECAUSE OF
WHERE WE ARE IN THE WAR.
MANY HAVE LIKENED AND POINTED TO
WINSTON CHURCHILL, THE FAMOUS
BRITISH WORLD WAR II LEADER AS
THE EPITOME OF A LEADER IN
WARTIME.
AND MANY IN THE LAST TEN MONTHS
IN UKRAINE HAVE COMPARED
ZELENSKYY AND HIS WARTIME
LEADERSHIP TO THAT OF WINSTON
CHURCHILL AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
IN THE RALLYING OF INTERNATIONAL
SUPPORT FOR THE DEFENSE OF
UKRAINE.
SO THIS IS MASSIVELY IMPORTANT.
HE WILL WANT ALL SORTS OF MODERN
WEAPONS.
HE'LL THANK FOR THE PATRIOT, THE
MOST SOPHISTICATED ANTI-AIR
MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEM HE'S GOT
SO FAR AND THAT'S AVAILABLE SO
FAR.
AND THEN THEY'RE GOING TO WANT
TO HAVE, PRESUMABLY OTHER THINGS
LIKE MORE AND MORE DRONES AND
SOPHISTICATED WEAPON SYSTEMS TO
COMBAT THE AIR THAT RUSSIA
CONTROLS WITH ITS MISSILE
ATTACKS.
SO THAT'S THE IMPORTANT THING.
ZELENSKYY IS BRINGING WITH HIM,
HE SAID IN HIS PRESS CONFERENCE,
A FLAT FROM THE SOLDIERS ON THE
FRONT LINE OF BAKHMUT, THAT'S
THE KEY TOWN IN THE EAST, ON THE
EASTERN FRONT THAT IT IS BEING
PUMMELLED AND FOUGHT OVER BY
BOTH RUSSIA AND UKRAINE.
THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE WENT
OVER THERE, MET WITH THE TROOPS,
TOOK A FLAG OF UKRAINE, HAD IT
SIGNED BY THE TROOPS AND SAID HE
WILL DELIVER IT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN THE AMERICAN CONGRESS
AS A MESSAGE OF THANKS.
WHEN I ASKED HIM, EVEN A MONTH
AGO, AND THEY STILL STICK TO
THIS, WHETHER IT'S ENOUGH
ALREADY AND THEY SHOULD BOW TO
CERTAIN SECTORS OF THE
INTERNATIONAL OPINION WHO SAY
THEY SHOULD NEGOTIATE, HE SAID
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
HE SAID THAT'S JUST WHAT PUTIN
WANTS.
HERE'S WHAT HE TOLD ME.
>> Translator: THE CURRENT
MILITARY AND POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP OF RUSSIA NEEDS A
PAUSE IN ONE FORM OR ANOTHER.
JUST LIKE AN AGREEMENT OR SOME
OTHER AGREEMENT THEY NEEDED A
PAUSE.
THEY WOULD GATHER UP THEIR
STRENGTH, MONEY, WEAPONS, THEY
WOULD GET READY, THEY WOULD LAY
OUT THE INFORMATION FOR THEIR
OWN SOCIETY.
AND WHEN ALL OF THAT HAS BEEN
PREPARED, THEY START THEIR
OFFENSIVE.
BECAUSE THERE IS ONLY ONE GOAL,
TO DESTROY OUR INDEPENDENCE.
>> Reporter: AND SO, THE
UKRAINIANS BELIEVE THAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE SOMEHOW PREPARING A
NEW GROUND OFFENSIVE, INCLUDING
KEEPING KYIV IN PLAY, OR SOME
TIME YOU KNOW, DURING OR AFTER
THE WINTER, ACCORDING TO FIONA
HILL, BASICALLY THE KREMLIN
WANTS TO TAKE UKRAINE OFF THE
MAP, AND STOP AID TO UKRAINE.
AND UKRAINE WANTS TO GET THE
KIND OF WEAPONS IT NEEDS TO
FIGHT FOR THE FIGHT THAT AMERICA
AND THE WORLD SAID IS ALL F OUR
FIGHT, THE FIGHT AGAINST
AUTOCRACY AND THE FIGHT FOR
DEMOCRACY.
>> CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MERRY CHRISTMAS TO YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANKS.
>> AND TO YOU.
>>> THIS MORNING, UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HIGHLY
SECRETIVE WHITE HOUSE VISIT IS
COMING UNDER EXTRAORDINARY
MEASURES.
JOINING US NOW KYLIE ATWOOD WITH
THE LATEST IN THIS.
WHAT KIND OF HEIGHTENED SECURITY
MEASURES ARE BEING TAKEN AT THIS
POINT?
>> Reporter: WE'LL KNOW MORE
ABOUT THAT AFTER THE VISIT HAS
CONCLUDED BECAUSE WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, ZELENSKYY IS
TRYING TO DO IS KEEP CLOSE TAPS
ON ALL INFORMATION ABOUT THIS
VISIT BECAUSE AS YOU SAID IT IS
RISKY.
THEY TRIED TO KEEP IT
CONFIDENTIAL AS LONG AS THEY
COULD.
BUT WE KNOW THERE WERE SECURITY
CONSULTATIONS BETWEEN THE U.S.
AND THOSE AROUND ZELENSKYY THAT
STARTED ABOUT A WEEK AGO.
AND PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAD
CONDITIONS THAT NEEDED TO BE
MET.
ONCE THOSE WERE MET, THEY DID
AND THEN CONFIRM THE TRIP WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
THAT HAPPENED ON SUNDAY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, SENIOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS AREN'T
SAYING HOW ZELENSKYY IS FLYING
HERE, COMING ON A U.S. MILITARY
AIRCRAFT OR NOT.
BUT WE'RE LEARNING THIS MORNING
NEW DETAILS FROM POLISH TV
BECAUSE THEY CAPTURED ZELENSKYY
COMING INTO POLAND OVER THE
UKRAINE BORDER ON A TRAIN, AND
THAT IS TRADITIONALLY HOW U.S.
LEADERS, LEADERS AROUND THE
WORLD HAVE GOTTEN IN AND OUT OF
UKRAINE ON THE TRAIN IN THE
COUNTRY, AND ON A FLIGHT OUT OF
POLAND.
THE OTHER THING THAT'S
NOTEWORTHY, HE WAS WITH THE U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE AND
NOTABLY TODAY, UKRAINE GOING TO
BE A FOCUS BUT WE SHOULD NOTE
THAT THE U.S. SENATE IS GOING TO
BE VOTING ON LYNN TRACEY.
THAEPS GOING TO BE THE FIRST
FEMALE AMBASSADOR TO RUSSIA,
REPLACING JOHN SULLIVAN, HER
NOMINATION WENT TO THE SENATE IN
SEPTEMBER, THEY'LL BE VOTING ON
HER TODAY.
IT'S SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE THIS IS
A DAY ALL ABOUT THE UNITED
STATES STANDING WITH UKRAINE BUT
OF COURSE IT IS NOTEWORTHY THAT
THE SENATE IS ALSO GOING TO BE
SENDING A NEW AMBASSADOR TO
RUSSIA.
>> AND THE WORLD WILL BE
WATCHING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH KYLIE
ATWOOD.
>> FOR MORE PERSPECTIVE, LET'S
BRING IN RETIRED LIEUTENANT
COLONEL ALEX VINMAN AND FORMER
AMBASSADOR BILL TAYLOR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
YOU'RE TWO EXPERTS IN THE AREA.
AMBASSADOR TAYLOR I'D LIKE TO
START WITH YOU ON HOW CRITICAL
THE VISIT IS AND WHAT YOU'LL BE
WATCHING FOR AS PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY MAKES SUCH A HISTORIC
TRIP TO THE UNITED STATES, HIS
FIRST TIME OUT OF UKRAINE SINCE
RUSSIA INVADED HIS COUNTRY.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, KAITLAN, A
GREAT VISIT, GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
HE WILL CERTAINLY -- PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY WILL CERTAINLY THANK
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THANK
PRESIDENT BIDEN, THE CONGRESS,
FOR ALL THE SUPPORT AND IT HAS
BEEN MAJOR.
IT'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT.
IT'S BEEN OVERWHELMING.
IT HAS BEEN HUGE.
THE SUPPORT THAT WE PROVIDED.
AND THE UKRAINIANS REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
AND PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS GOING
TO REFLECT ALL THE UKRAINIAN
VIEWS THAT APPRECIATE ALL THE
SUPPORT THEY'VE GOTTEN AND THEY
NEED IT TO CONTINUE AND TO
EXPAND AND THAT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
COMING.
>> AMBASSADOR, JUST ONE MORE FOR
YOU BEFORE WE GET TO LIEUTENANT
VINDMAN.
DO YOU REMEMBER BACK IN APRIL
WHEN THIS -- ALMOST AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE WAR, NEARLY TWO
MONTHS IN, AND YOU HAD BORIS
JOHNSON WALKING AROUND KYIV,
VISITING ZELENSKYY IN KYIV.
THAT WAS IN COUNTRY.
AND NOW YOU HAVE THIS VISIT.
PEOPLE WILL COMPARE THESE TWO
VISITS.
BUT THE BIG DIFFERENCE IS THAT
ONE WAS ON UKRAINIAN SOIL AND
NOW THIS IS ON U.S. SOIL.
THAT IS A VERY BIG DIFFERENCE.
>> IT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE.
IT SHOWS, THOUGH, DON, THAT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAS
IDENTIFIED THE UNITED STATES AS
A MAJOR SUPPORTER, THE LEADER OF
THE COALITION, THE LEADER OF
THIS BROAD ASSEMBLY OF NATIONS
SUPPORTING UKRAINE AND OPPOSING
THE UNJUSTIFIED RUSSIAN
INVASION.
SO THAT IS A STRONG SIGNAL OF
THE COOPERATION AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE ALLIANCE
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES AND
UKRAINE.
>> COLONEL VINDMAN, THIS PATRIOT
MISSILE SYSTEM THAT THE U.S. IS
GOING TO SEND TO UKRAINE, WE
HEARD FROM OFFICIALS SAYING IT'S
GOING TO TAKE A WHILE, THEY HAVE
TO TRAIN IN A THIRD PARTY
COUNTRY TO GET THEM TRAINED ON
HOW TO USE THIS.
THAT IS A HUGE FOCUS, ONE OF THE
MOST POWERFUL WEAPONS IN THE
U.S. ARSENAL.
DO YOU EXPECT PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY TO ASK FOR MORE GIVEN
THAT -- THIS IS NOT SIGNALING
THAT THE WAR IS COMING TO AN END
ANY TIME SOON.
>> TO ME THE DELIVERY OR THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE PATRIOT
MISSILE SYSTEM IS IMPORTANT BUT
FRANKLY LESS IMPORTANT THAN A
SIGNAL THAT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
IS PREPARED TO PROVIDE OTHER
ADVANCED CAPABILITIES AND THE
U.S. IS GOING TO START TRAINING
UKRAINE ON HOW TO OPERATE
EVERYTHING FROM AIRCRAFT, LIKE
F-16s, F-15s.
TANKS ARE IN THE MIX.
STARTING TO TRAIN FORCES ON THE
TANKS.
THESE ARE SYSTEMS THAT ARE
COMPLEX AND REQUIRE TRAINING.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
THAT THE UKRAINIANS FACE AT THE
MOMENT IS THEY NEED AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF EQUIPMENT AND OVER THE
COURSE OF ON TEN MONTHS A LOT OF
IT HAS STARTED TO BREAK DOWN.
SO A BROADER MORE STRATEGIC
RELATIONSHIP AND A MORE
STRATEGIC VIEW ON SUSTAINING
THIS WAR FOR THE NEXT SIX TO
NINE MONTHS IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL.
I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY WHY
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS MAKE THIS
TRIP NOW.
HE'S -- IT'S HALFTIME, HE'S RUN
UP THE SCORE REAL HIGH.
THE END GAME IS THE SPRING AND
SUMMER AND HE'S GOING TO PUSH
THROUGH UNTIL HE LIBERATES THE
ENTIRETY OF HIS COUNTRY AND HE'S
LOOKING FOR THE U.S., HIS
STRATEGIC PARTNER, ALLY, TO WADE
IN WITH THE SAME KIND OF